the Greek gods are notorious for petty
squabbling brutal punishments and
meddling in people's love lives but in
the myth of Prometheus and Immortal
makes the ultimate sacrifice for the
sake of humankind a Wily Titan who stole
fire from the gods and gave it to humans
Prometheus represents risk progress and
generally sticking it to the Man Zeus
who usually didn't take kindly to any of
those things
across World myth we find fire seizing
Rebels who defy the defying order and
ignite human potential some are punished
while some are praised but what's so
shocking about stealing a little spark
Prometheus is often portrayed as a
trickster but is that a fair depiction I
think and I'll die on this Cliff when
you've looked closer Prometheus is a
more complex character than you might
expect
[Music]
to understand the significance of
Prometheus we have to go way back to
before the creation of humankind at this
time two groups of gods were battling
for control of the cosmos the Titans led
by Kronos were the Divine Children Of
Heaven and Earth shout out to the Gaia
episode The Olympians led by Zeus were a
younger generation of gods hungry for
power these two Mighty groups seemed
equally matched but the Titan Prometheus
whose name means foresight saw that the
Olympians would eventually Triumph he
persuaded his brother Epimetheus to
switch sides with him just in time sure
enough Zeus defeated the Titans casting
them into eternal hell as a token of his
thanks Zeus gave the brothers an
important task creating life on Earth
Epimetheus formed the animals while
Prometheus shaped the first humans from
mud he made them in the image of the
Gods but their bodies were merely mortal
Zoo saw these new formed humans as puny
only good for worshiping Gods from afar
but Prometheus recognizes the dignity in
his fragile creations and he wanted to
give them an advantage when Zeus decreed
that humans should sacrifice half an
animal to the gods Prometheus killed an
animal and presented it in two parts
Zeus chose the meteor part leaving the
skin and bones for Mortals but when he
examined the meat he saw that Prometheus
had hidden the succulent flesh under the
less attractive Parts leaving only
gristle for the Gods
Furious Zeus withheld fire from the
earth leaving the first humans hungry
and cold but this only made Prometheus
more inclined to help us scaling Mount
Olympus he lit a torch from the Sun God
Apollo's Chariot hidden in a hollow
fennel stock and smuggled it back down
to Earth with fire Prometheus bestowed a
powerful tool now humans can nourish and
care for themselves but it also meant
they could Forge weapons and wage war
they learned new skills lived longer and
traveled to Faraway lands ultimately
ruling above all other living things
some on Olympus saw Prometheus as a
triumphant Trailblazer who gave Mortals
the ability to progress others viewed
him as a shadowy figure who unlocked
humans appetite for greed and conflict
and others denounced him as a supreme
Troublemaker who needed to be taken down
you can probably guess what camp Zeus
was in as punishment Zeus bound
Prometheus to a remote Cliff every day
vultures swooped down on him and tore
out his liver and every night his liver
grew back ready to be devoured again in
some versions Prometheus is trapped for
eternity in others Zeus eventually
allows Heracles to free him but only
because he needs prometheus's help
despite his grisly punishment we rarely
see Prometheus expressing remorse in
hessian's theogony he's a gleeful
trickster who happily flouts Zeus's
Authority in a series of Dramas usually
ascribed to escalus he's a more cerebral
figure who waxes philosophical about the
boundary between Heaven and Earth and in
the Poetry of Ovid he's a Visionary
according to Ovid Prometheus shaped
humans with upturned faces so they could
look towards the skies and upright raise
their face to the Stars here it's
Prometheus that gives Humanity our
thirst for knowledge and the ability to
advance civilization
these myths imagine the transformation
of fire from a divire mysterious entity
into something that can be hoarded
stolen and shared but fire is never an
ordinary resource rather it gives humans
the power to light their own way fire
thieves are dangerous figures because
they suggest that Divine Authority is
not absolute it can be tricked twisted
and in some cases seized for ourselves
for transgressing the boundary between
Heaven and Earth several Promethean
figures suffer grisly Fates dating to
the Bronze Age a Georgian myth tells of
the hero amarani known for outsmarting
dragons and battling Giants his downfall
comes when he tells humans the secrets
of metalwork which had previously been
reserved for the gods as punishment
amarani is chained to a cliff in the
Caucasus Mountains where an eagle
devours his liver every day amarani does
have a trusty dog who gnaws at his
chains but every year the gods come back
to repair it the vinic people of the
north caucuses also told of a demigod
paharmat whose stole fire from the
heavens he pitied the humans known as
narts who had nothing but cold milk and
raw food the only source of fire
belonged to the god of skies and storms
Cela who hoarded it in his Chariot with
the help of salah's wife SATA paharmat
stole a blazing flame for all this he
was you guessed it chained to a cliff
and eaten by scavenger Birds
crucially paharmat carried Fire Down to
Earth in a hollow Reed eventually the
fire burned through its container and
made tiny holes creating the first Reed
pipe thus he brings not only fire but
music to humanity in this example a
Promethean figure is associated with
creativity as well as progress although
while some people refused to recognize
it Prometheus was a creative himself
Potter activist artist prankster
whatever you want to call him it's hard
to ignore his agency and that agency
inspires Humanity the interpretation of
Prometheus as an imaginative Spirit was
particularly popular with the romantics
a group of writers artists and
intellectuals who saw subjectivity
individualism and emotional Freedom as
Paramount during the 19th century Mary
Shelley's husband Percy wrote the
romantic drama Prometheus Unbound in
which the Titan is a hero who spreads a
message of love and empowerment his
friend the poet Lord Byron also stand
Prometheus he wrote The Godly crime was
to be kind and strengthen manned with
his own mind Mary Shelley imagine
Prometheus as a more cautionary figure
in Frankenstein in which the titular
scientist makes a humanoid figure and
just can't deal with his creation the
novel is subtitled the modern Prometheus
suggesting the danger of tampering with
the natural order and the disastrous
results of misdirected human ambition to
this day Prometheus is a shorthand for
Progress a quick Google will tell you
that a lot of companies like to
reference the original disrupter but
while billionaires who want to fly to
the moon might Market themselves as
path-breaking Prometheans what sets them
apart from the real deal is that
Prometheus was always fighting for those
less powerful than himself in their
ancient mythical forms Promethean
figures imbue humans with the potential
to reach new heights but they also stand
in for our hopes and anxieties about
what humans do with their power many
also remind us that with great power
comes great responsibility